they call it the people's house but it
feels like a scorched
battlefield fortified scarred
and exposed by a siege
now surrounded by more u.s troops than
are deployed in iraq and afghanistan
combined
in trump's america this is what a push
for a peaceful transfer of power looks
like
where the democrat speaker of the house
plays the role of commander-in-chief
hope that the fact that you will fear
will be a deterrent to those who have
come to undermine
our constitution moments later
came this donald trump impeached for the
second time
on this vote the eyes are 232
the nays are 197.
the resolution is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the
table it was a bleak day
in the annals of america the leader of
the free world
charged with inciting violence against
his own government
the president must be impeached and i
believe the president must be convicted
by the senate
a constitutional remedy that will ensure
that the republic will be safe from this
man who was so resolutely determined
to tear down the things that we hold
dear
and that hold us together he must go
he is a clear and present danger to the
nation
that we all love the images
outside as stark as the arguments within
a room full of people that feared they
could have been
obliterated the mob could have blown the
building
up they could have killed us all
donald trump is a living breathing
impeachable
offense it is what it is
to ardent trump loyalists the blame lies
solely with the rioters mop
not the man they follow now it's
impeachment round two
it's always been about getting the
president no matter what
but the earth has shifted under donald
trump
some of his own fighting to purge him
from the party
my vote to impeach our sitting president
is not a fear-based decision
i am not choosing a side i'm choosing
truth it's the only way to defeat fear
the gentlewoman even his allies struggle
to muster a defense
the president bears responsibility for
wednesday's attack on congress by mob
rioters
he should have immediately denounced the
mob when he saw what was unfolding
these facts require immediate action by
president trump
accept his share of responsibility quell
the brewing unrest after no contrition
and
no twitter came an 11th hour statement
from the president in light of reports
of more demonstrations he said
i urge that there must be no violence no
law breaking and no vandalism of any
kind
this is not what i stand for and it's
not what america stands for
i call on all americans to help ease
tensions
and calm tempers thank you
but they lay in wait for the worst
knowing how easy it was
just days ago for this building to be
breached
this feels very surreal troops
everywhere you look
some trying to catch some sleep others
eating
clutching their firearms subdued but
well aware there could be a storm ahead
the president will leave office just as
he entered it
in a blaze of controversy but democrats
want to make sure he can never return
and this time
they may be able to persuade some on the
other side
cordelia lynch sky news washington